ranjan via Skype by the GP dr. Hamid
Khan so dr. Khan is is this your expense
are you operating at your very limit
absolutely that's the key for cross the
board in general practice at the moment
we have a situation where we have an
aging population which is increasingly
complex both from a medical perspective
because they often have complex multiple
chronic conditions often intertwined
with social issues as well which are
intractable and which are very difficult
to manage so that means that the health
burden on general practice and the NHS
has increased massively over the last
few years and in addition to that we
also have had a situation where funding
has flatlined over the last few years
and as a result of that the intensity of
the workload in general practice has
increased the complexity has increased
and GPS are burning out we have a higher
rate of burnout than past we have ever
had before a lot of GPS or retiring as
soon as they can thousands are
emigrating GP training places are empty
in many places up to about thirty
percent even in some areas and this is a
literary huge shortage of GP so much so
that it's very difficult to start the
normal routine five-day service let
alone stretch it to a routine seven-day
service the problem is democracy really
dr. gharn I mean in that the
Conservative Party said that they wanted
to introduce this this seven-day this
truly seven-day-a-week NHS and they were
elected into office they now have the
push to make this a reality so it's in
this just a case of you having to adapt
to what the government and in effect
what the people of Britain want look I'd
be delighted to have a 24-7 GP service
but the fact of the matter is that there
are not enough gps for the routine
five-day service at the moment there are
there is a situation where practices
have been advertising for gps and have
often had vacancies which have been
unfilled for a year or even longer so if
we
can't get GPS into positions where they
provide the routine five-day services
it's impossible to think that we will be
able to recruit enough GPS to provide
services on Saturdays and Sundays the
issue is nothing to do with democracy
really the factors that we simply don't
have enough funding or enough resource
for the number of GPS that would be to
provide routine seven-day services
that's the fundamental issue here we've
had a flat lining of funding over the
last year and as I said earlier the
complexity of health issues and the
aging population mean that the workload
is much more intense and much more
complex than it has been in the past so
when you have resources which are not
increasing but a health burden which is
increasing and is becoming more
complicated it's clear that you won't be
able to stretch the service even more
because it's difficult to provide the
current levels of service as it is
you're obviously tainting a fairly
gloomy picture here I mean is this just
purely about money as this what it what
the NHS needs at the moment is being
starved as the cash necessary to deal
with these challenges that it's facing I
think to a large expenditures I mean
those the statistics are in front of us
as a percentage of our national wealth
we spend lower amounts on health than
the average developed country does that
the matter of fact that's a matter of
statistical fact nobody can dispute that
but in addition what I'd ideally want to
be is an end to the constant
restructuring that we continually have
the different governments and different
political parties and so on and
ultimately a detachment of the NHS and
the running of the NHS from party
politics and what we need to enable that
is some sort of cross party commission
or cross-party consensus which almost
goes above party politics and above for
your electoral terms to take
evidence-based decisions which are in
the interest of the NHS so what we need
to do is uncouple politics from the
running of the NHS together with
increased funding
dr. Khan we're very grateful for your
time thanks very much indeed